pékin état d'insurrection pour la
première fois soldats et manifestants
s'affrontent bilan 16 morts et plus de
180 blessés du côté des manifestants
88 % des salariés et des chefs
d'entreprises français sont d'accord
pour dire que la propreté sur les lieux
de travail est très importante mais 54%
des personnes interrogées sont obligés
de faire eux mêmes le ménage de leur
poste de travail enquête dans ce journal
maradona sur la canebière ce n'est pas
la dernière histoire marseillaise l'om
serait en tractation pour acheter le
célèbre joueur argentin de naples pour
la modique somme de 4 milliards de
centimes mai dernier épisode à l'instant
maradona dit non je reste à nabeul à
naples pardon qu'elle pastis madame
monsieur bonsoir depuis cette semaine à
pékin le face à face entre étudiants et
forces de l'ordre étaient restés non
violent mais aujourd'hui samedi les
soldats ont voulu une nouvelle fois
dégagé le centre de la ville ils ont dû
reculer devant la population descendus
dans la rue mais l'affrontement a eu
lieu et le bilan ce soir salle tablit
autour de 16 morts du côté des
manifestants et environ 180 blessés sur
place à pékin
notre envoyé spécial bruno le dreff
estime que la situation peut être
qualifiée d'insurrection armée formée
pendant près de deux heures de nombreux
mois les combats que l'on a plus d'une
reprise
vers une heure du matin était alors 18
heures à paris les tromper d'entrée en
même temps pékin une centaine de camions
et ailleurs dans les buts se sont
dirigés vers les domaines dont les voir
et à plusieurs reprises la radio et la
télévision lil wayne et les décliner la
population d'être mais elle est ensuite
été demandé aux béninois de rentrer chez
ses versements il est clair l'armée est
intervenue
les habitants de l'est cabinet lil wayne
était alors descendu en main dans la rue
le port les principaux carrefours et des
mairies iard et vie plusieurs convois
militaires est encore l'heure de la
parole et les costards demande de
réprimer leur demande et en différents
endroits et le sigle nbg à l'instant
même j'apprends que les soldats de
l'armée chinoise ont investi la place
tienanmen qu'ils ont dégagé atrous de
grenades de lacrymogènes nous sommes en
train d'appeler à l'instant notre envoyé
spécial bruno de rêve que nous aurons
dans le courant de ce journal pour les
dernières précisions
retour en france en attendant il s'agit
d'une actualité passer pour ceux qui ont
la chance d'avoir un emploi mais pas
pour ceux qui après avoir épuisé toutes
les ressources des allocations chômage
se retrouve sans rien pour eux il ya
cinq mois maintenant a été décidé
l'attribution d'un revenu minimum
d'insertion le et rim
comment fonctionne-t-il sur le terrain
n'est-il qu'une allocation de plus ou un
véritable moyen de réintégrer la société
enquête à toulouse de valérie fournioux
et gilles berrut comme si la fatalité
les poursuivaient
robert chômeurs longue durée habite rue
de la manche dans la cité rose et
déshérité en banlieue de toulouse depuis
neuf ans son univers celui des exclus
l'univers de la mine
le rmi arrive à temps ça m'a évité à
faire des conneries parce que la jetée
là j'étais vraiment j'étais vraiment la
limite je te prie je sais pas moi aller
voler dans les magasins s'il le fallait
parce que moi comment moi moi moi il
faut de la viande pour mes gars que je
sais pas comment expliquer ça il faut de
la viande pour mais est-ce que si jamais
je donne qu'à neuf jeunes caennais fin à
mes gosses vous inquiétez pas il me faut
remarquer et ça ça ça fait pas du reste
avec les 1950 francs du rmi
robert rembourse ses dettes et vit grâce
à des petits boulots des emplois
saisonniers qu'il arrive à trouver mais
son contrat avec l'état va beaucoup plus
loin
la mise en place vers rémy est une
oeuvre remarquable mais effectivement
elle est pour nous l'occasion de nous
remettre en cause et de voir le problème
du travail social d'une nouvelle manière
c'est une politique c'est un tout et il
faut à tout prix le voir à travers les
problèmes de santé les problèmes de
logement les problèmes parfois
d'alphabétisation les problèmes de mise
en condition pour savoir se préparer à
des prêts stage de formation à des
stages et on le fait au travail
réinsérer et surtout redonner la
confiance en soi des objectifs du
mouvement gavroche et toulouse car eux
la galerie connaissent ils touchent le
rémy mais en plus qu'on le choix d'aider
les autres ceux qui ne pensaient même
plus aller dans les centres sociaux on
se dit que la terre a toujours tourné
chacun pour soi et voilà où ça nous mène
on en est maintenant à un point où la
misère est de plus en plus insoutenable
de plus en plus forte
nous sommes là pour la traquer et donc
nos prétentions c'est d'essayer de
solidariser les gens un peu de façon à
ce qu'il y ait un peu moins de personnes
dans l'oubli et livrés à eux mêmes dans
une visière certaines où ils ne pourront
pas en sortir
faute d'information faute de
possibilités le revenu minimum
d'insertion commence à se faire
connaître dans ce milieu où pourtant
l'information ne circule que de bouche à
oreille c'est peut-être là une première
réussie je vous dit à l'instant juste
avant ce reportage que les soldats de
l'armée chinoise venait après sept
semaines de manifestations d'investir la
place centrale de pékin la place
tienanmen juste qui jusqu'à ce soir
était tenu par les étudiants et les
manifestants de pékin
ces soldats viennent d'investir la place
j'ai tout de suite au téléphone notre
envoyé spécial bruno ledru bruno oui
daniel comme vous venez de le dire
l'armée populaire de libération a pris
position plein et nan men il s'agit de
milliers de soldats au moins nous avons
vu passer des camions pendant près d'une
heure des camions remplis de soldats
ainsi que des chars nous en avons compté
une trentaine mais il faut également que
vous et c'est que la population de pékin
semble refuser l'ordre militaire qu'on
tente de lui imposer la population
civile est validée dans la rue malgré la
présence militaire
elles se dirigent maintenant en nombre
vers la place tiananmen en criant à bas
les soldats en traitant les soldats de
ben 10 la traduction littérale de ce qui
leur est dû ynwa et la pause chante
l'internationale d'autant de dirigeants
pour l'instant vers la place tiananmen
alors que l'armée continue à tirer on
entend des tirs de l'endroit où nous
nous trouvons actuellement
merci bruno bien entendu si d'autres
informations vous parvenaient tout de
suite nous vous prendrions à l'antenne
retour en france le président de la
république monsieur françois mitterrand
assistait ce matin à la clôture du
congrès des hlm les habitations à loyer
modéré l'occasion pour lui de réaffirmer
la priorité accordée à l'habitat social
mais entre les où le discours et les
crédits l'adéquation est loin d'être
parfaite reportage de jean pellieux aimé
mayol
c'est avec un a priori favorable que le
congrès a accueilli françois mitterrand
le chef de l'état en effet n'a pas cessé
ces derniers mois d'affirmer son
attachement au logement social
les responsables hlm et notamment leur
président roger quilliot demande plus
c'est à dire des mesures concrètes
l'état pour eux accordent trop davantage
aux ménages aisés
il faut que ces aides au logement ait en
priorité aux ménages modestes
je partage votre jugement a dit françois
mitterrand assurant que le logement
serait après l'éducation la seconde
priorité de la nation gouvernement
prendra les premières mesures en ce sens
cette année mais il faudra plus de temps
pour qu'intervienne à les réformes en
profondeur
je veillerai à ce que les évolutions se
fasse dans le cadre du budget de l'état
incitation collectivités locales et je
veux vous dire ici ma conviction que
l'absolue priorité désormais doit tendre
à l'accès des plus défavorisés à un
logement un vrai logement de taille et
de qualité suffisante au moment où
parler le chef de l'état quelques
milliers de personnes ont manifesté à
l'appel de la cnl la principale
association de locataires
parmi leurs revendications le blocage
des loyers et des crédits attribués tout
de suite aux logements sociaux et à
leurs occupants
ce que je souhaite en tout cas c'est
qu'au delà des grandes déclarations
d'intention généreuse sur les questions
du logement social soient prises des
mesures financières législatives
indispensable nous nous opposons un
système qui consiste à concevoir le
logement comme une marchandise
logement c'est un besoin imprescriptible
des familles
on ne veut pas voir aussi bien les
locataires du secteur à sean que du
secteur privé connaître en permanence
des hausses qui viennent réduire encore
plus un pouvoir d'achat qui pour le
moins qu'on puisse dire stagne chaque
année c'est en juillet que son
revaloriser les aides aux logements
suivant leur majoration
on verra concrètement si le gouvernement
a commencé ou non à faire de nouveau une
priorité du logement social
c'est demain que les polonais vont voter
pour élire presque démocratiquement
depuis la fin de la dernière guerre leur
sénat et leurs parlements presque
démocratiquement dans la mesure où une
partie des sièges la majorité des deux
tiers
restera encore acquise au parti
communiste mais des candidats libres en
principe ceux du syndicat solidarité ont
obtenu le droit de se présenter mais
cette élection a déjà fait de gagnant
avant l'heure
l'église polonaise qui a de nouveau
obtenu officiellement droit de cité et
les écologistes qui ont fait leur
intrusion leur apparition dans un pays
où l'industrie n'a pas ménagé
l'environnement reportage de jacques
merlino et claude sicard à la veille du
premier tour de ces élections
historiques
il y a déjà deux vainqueurs en pologne
l'église et les écologistes l'église le
manifester avec puissance lors de la
fêtée partout en pologne
ce jour-là elle organisa des cortèges
imposants
montant qu'à elles seules elles
pouvaient regrouper 10 cents ou mille
fois plus de fidèles que l'on ne compte
de participants dans les meetings
électoraux
de fait et cela ne fut guère souligne
elle a réussi à tout obtenir du pouvoir
lors des négociations de la table ronde
l'état s'est engagé à lui à situer tous
les biens saisis depuis 1947 ou à
l'indemniser ce qui représenterait
plusieurs millions de dollars
l'église est maintenant autorisée à
ouvrir des écoles religieuses des
hôpitaux et pourra organiser toute
activité économique qui lui semble
nécessaire
enfin les soixante deux mille membres de
son clergé bénéficieront dorénavant de
la sécurité sociale une église nettement
engagé dans la bataille politique les
paroles de ce chant religieux sont
claires dieu est de ne pas garder notre
terre à la rendre du port
oh
second vainqueur
les écologistes il est vrai qu'ils sont
beaucoup dire la mère de la baltique est
complètement peut lui l'industrie
massacrent allègrement l'environnement
et les terres agricoles rocaille les
plus acides
venus d'allemagne tous les candidats ces
phases et séduire et sur penche plutôt
du côté de solidarnosc
ils tiennent à montrer leurs différences
ce n'est pas la peine de construire des
centrales électriques se tramer sombre
qui cette banderole de vainqueur et
peut-être déjà à perdre en les étudiants
malgré une semaine de grève et
d'occupation des universités le pouvoir
refuse toujours de reconnaître leur
syndicat la nzs puiseaux pour le moment
suspendu leur mouvement
et puis une interrogation dans quel état
sortira le parti communiste de ces
élections
certes il est assuré par les accords de
la table ronde d'occuper au moins les
deux tiers de la chambre des députés
et cela quel que soit le verdict les
yeux mais ces candidats à dire eh bien
peu de public de leurs meetings et l'on
voyait parfois comme ici quasiment plus
de monde sur l'estrade que dans la salle
reste que l'élection du dimanche 4 juin
sera très intéressante sur un point
particulier pour des raisons étranges le
gouvernement a pris le risque insensé de
présenter sur une liste à part 35
personnalités dont le premier ministre
le mr défense le ministre l'intérieur le
patron des syndicats officiels
si lundi ces personnes ne sont pas élus
c'est toute une partie de la structure
officielle du pouvoir en pologne qui
sera publiquement désavoué deux
originalités dans le dernier voyage du
pape de norvège en islande jean paul ii
visite de pays presque entièrement
protestants et puis il est sans doute le
premier pape de l'histoire à avoir
dépassé le cercle polaire dominique
verdeilhan à tromsø et à 350 km au nord
du cercle polaire la curiosité
bienveillante a succédé à l'indifférence
des norvégiens devant le voyage papal
dans ce haut lieu de la religion
réformée de lutter seulement 700 des
50000 habitants de ce port norvégiens
sont de religion catholique l'évêque
luthérien n'a d'ailleurs pas assister à
la prière vespérale prétextant d'autres
engagements
nous sommes réunis ce soir en ce long
crépuscule du nord sous un soleil qui ne
se couche pas et symbolise si bien le
christ a déclaré en norvégien jean paul
ii le pape a défendu les valeurs du
mariage et de la famille face à des
fidèles qui pratiquent le concubinage et
sont peu d'enfants en islande à
reykjavík le papa continue de plaider en
faveur de la réconciliation des
chrétiens afin dit il de maintenir
l'unité de l'esprit
cet après midi jean paul ii a été reçu
par madame finnbogadottir la présidente
de la république islandaise et le
saint-père on parler écologie
l'islande est l'un des pays les plus
propres du monde prochaine étape papale
la finlande
le danemark et la suède après le débat à
vif c'est l'heure de l'affrontement réel
entre israéliens partisans de la manière
forte dans les territoires occupés et
d'autres qui pensent que l'on pourra
rien résout de cette façon il faut dire
que toutes les méthodes ont été essayées
par le gouvernement et l'armée de
jérusalem et jusqu'à présent il faut l'y
rien n'a réussi la révolte des pierres
continuent de jérusalem notre
correspondant charles enderlin rosheim
un village de 4000 habitants fait de ppr
l'unité de parachutistes est en train de
laver se dire les jeunes palestiniens
qui faisait le guet ont été neutralisés
et à 5 heures du matin les villageois se
réveille en découvrant les soldats à
leur porte
les paras savent exactement qui arrêtait
ils vont de maison en maison avec des
listes de suspects selon les officiels
s'agit d'agitateurs repéré de longue
date l'opération filmé pour la première
fois par une télévision étrangère se
déroule sans bavure pas un jet de pierre
pas un coup de feu pas de brutalité
il y à 28 arrestations
les officiers sont satisfaits des
villages comme celui ci qui n'ont pas
été visités par l'armée pendant quelques
mois deviennent des fiefs de l'eau et
lui et en les prenant ainsi par surprise
nous les mettons en état de choc ils
n'ont même pas eu le temps de nous
lancer des pierres
les prisonniers sont emmenés vers un
centre de détention
l'armée quitte le village
nous y sommes revenus une semaine plus
tard les slogans du soulèvement et herpa
là où les soldats les avait effacé des
signatures fattar ou armée populaire
palestinienne
des pierres sont prêtes pour barrer la
route à la prochaine patrouille qui
passera parfois ça les habitants sont en
colère ils n'ont pas encore de nouvelles
des jeunes arrêtés la semaine dernière
et dans le cimetière pendant que des
enfants faisait le guet nous avons
rencontré un responsable de
l'organisation clandestine du village
l'autre ne s'arrêtera pas à la suite de
ces arrestations
l'intifada le soulèvement est un
phénomène collectif
déjà au début il ya 18 mois la vague
d'arrestations n'avait eu aucun effet
sur nous au contraire ceux qui avaient
été arrêtés pour avoir lancé des pierres
sont revenus en voulant lancer des
cocktails molotov à roanne le
soulèvement continu
19h11 dépêche urgente en provenance de
téhéran l'imam khomeiny qui vient d'être
opéré des intestins et victime de
complications ses médecins s'efforcent
d'y faire face le communiqué laconique
ne dit pas plus
il appelle simplement le peuple à la pré
campagne pour les élections européennes
une grande réunion publique cet après
midi à paris la tête de liste socialiste
laurent fabius en famille soutenue par
pierre mauroy reportage de rachid arhab
et gilbert usant le fils de laurent
fabius est venu on mutile de son
illustre papa avec un illustré avait il
peur de s'ennuyer pendant les discours
avait-il entendu dire par son père que
la campagne européenne est ennuyeuse pas
de réponse l'autre attraction médiatique
de l'après midi le travailliste anglais
neil kinnock il y avait bien longtemps
car représentant de la gauche
d'outre-manche n'avait participé à un
meeting socialiste français un meeting
organisé par pierre mauroy qui a
beaucoup ironisé cet après-midi sur la
droite française les rénovateurs son
chagrin
pasqua ronge son frein
lecanu et ironise ces gains confort par
un silence baba l'échec des rénovateurs
le coeur n'est pas très coordonnée
c'est même la cacophonie mais cacophonie
surtout parce que la droite ne joue pas
sa partition
elle s'en faut son air européen
ou plutôt elle hésite entre deux heures
quant à laurent fabius il a surtout
vanté les mérites de ce qu'ils appellent
leur gauche l'europe socialiste défendu
par l'ancien premier ministre avec une
fougue de plus en plus fort à gauche
parce que la gauche c'est la jeunesse du
monde le fils de laurent fabius a
visiblement apprécié le discours de son
papa sur la jeunesse européenne
tout le monde est donc reparti content
c'est la liste centriste madame veil à
rouen s'interroge elle sur ce que fera
justement le député européen laurent
fabius lorsqu'il sera élu en juin
prochain président de l'assemblée
nationale dit elle il ne pourra siéger
régulièrement à strasbourg il serait
donc intéressant dit perfidement madame
veil une aussi grande personnalité
décide de démissionner de l'assemblée
nationale cela impressionnerait sans
doute les autres députés européens et
konami pour aller à new york qui ne sera
plus nécessaire aux provinciaux de
passer par paris en effet pour
harmoniser la concurrence entre air
france et ut à et répondre également aux
adversaires européens le ministre des
transports monsieur d'holbach a décidé
d'autoriser les deux compagnies à des
vols vers les états unis en partance de
toulouse bordeaux mulhouse strasbourg
marseille et lille sondage très
intéressant réalisé pour une grande
entreprise de nettoyage industriel gsf
par l'institut de sondage louis harris
le thème le titre la propreté dans
l'entreprise 54 % des personnes
interrogées répondent qu'elles font
souvent le ménage de l'endroit où elle
travaille
88 % des salariés et des chefs
d'entreprise estiment par ailleurs que
la propre t a une grande influence sur
l'ambiance de travail et puis encore la
propreté doit être considéré comme un
objectif de qualité c'est également un
indice de modernisme de l'entreprise
enquête jacques violet et vincent
maillard la propreté le nettoyage
d'entreprises passent de plus en plus
par des sociétés industrielles
spécialisées
si le balai brosse la serpillière et le
chiffon n'ont pas disparu les grosses
machines et même les rebonds sont
arrivés parmi les entreprises les plus
concernés par la propreté pour des
raisons d'hygiène évidente les
supermarchés et l'agroalimentaire ou
dans certaines sociétés des progrès
restent à faire ici avant l'ouverture 20
personnes des professionnels préparent
le magasin dix mille mètres carrés de
surface de vente les plus gros problèmes
sont les stocks les réserves
tous les emballages la casse sont broyés
compact et au fur et à mesure reste le
nettoyage du magasin pendant la journée
pendant la vente quatre personnes à
plein temps
comme seul on a environ 10 millions par
jour le volume de marchandises
nous avons dans le magasin où ça que
10000 clients dans le magasin c'est des
pots de moutarde cccd your par terre
c'est des salades moi qu'il faut
continuellement voir des personnes dont
adéquate et professionnel avant tout qui
passe sans arrêt sans arrêt combien ça
vous coûte l'entretien entre 150 et 200
mille francs par mois un budget
nettoyage qui ne représente que 0 30% du
chiffre d'affaires
cette enquête sur la propreté dans
l'entreprise montre que tout le monde va
tromper salariés s'accordent pour
reconnaître que la propreté influence le
comportement social et améliore
l'ambiance générale
elle a également des répercussions
positives sur la qualité du travail et
la productivité les entreprises
françaises sont dans une bonne moyenne
par rapport à leurs concurrentes
européennes important puisque la
propreté de l'entreprise influencent le
choix des clients
enfin au palmarès les secteurs de pointe
les entreprises les plus propres
l'électronique l'informatique parmi les
plus sales les entreprises de presse
balayons devant notre porte voici par
exemple des bureaux de journalistes pas
facile d'y faire le ménage
même pour des professionnels j'en
profite donc pour ranger mon bureau tout
de suite le sport maintenant ce n'est
pas une histoire marseillaise la
dernière histoire en date le journal
l'équipe révélait ce matin que des
pourparlers étaient entamées entre
l'olympique de marseille et le plus
célèbre argentin du monde diego maradona
qui joue actuellement à l'appeler puis
ce soir on apprend donc à l'instant que
le contrat envisagé qui était de 4
milliards ne sera sans doute pas perçu
puisque maradona vient de dire non alain
vernon maradona marseille on pouvait
s'attendre à des réactions de la part
des joueurs de l'olympique de marseille
venus préparer leur match contre auxerre
en coupe de france
ici dans un hôtel de troyes dans l'aube
malheureusement vous allez le voir
aucune réaction 17 heures cet après midi
après une sieste et une collation les
marseillais quittent leur hôtel de trois
pour auxerre 80 km en car inhabituelle
pour l'om qui a choisi au dernier moment
un itinéraire différent et la politique
du silence à l'image
jean pierre papin ça va pas pas un mot
sur mare de la déclaration après le
match jean-pierre enfin donné la
consigne a donc été respectée et par
tous pas de déclaration publique
même si l'om avouant privé ne parlait
que de maradona depuis 24 heures en tout
cas à marseille à la fièvre du titre de
champion de france a succédé la rumeur
bernard tapie et michel hidalgo se sont
isolés au large de cannes sur le bateau
du président tapis et maradona lui
alimente toutes les conversations
maradona récent champion d'europe avec
naples pourrait devenir le plus gros
transfert du football français ce matin
pour 40 millions de francs soit
pratiquement la moitié du budget de l'om
alors que le club italien l'avait acquis
en 84 pour 80 millions de francs après
l'argentine donc barcelone et nappes
maradona se disaient prêts à choisir la
france pour trois en or ce soir le
champion du monde âgé de 28 ans dément
son possible transfert à marseille ou
ailleurs et confirme qu'il restera à
naples jusqu'en 1993 terme de son
contrat fin du premier épisode le tennis
maintenant roland garros journée en
dents de scie pour les français deux
éliminés potier face à l'américain
duncan karine quintrec devant la
sud-africaine codeurs et un qualifié
thierry quillan qui a battu son
compatriote jean philippe florian à
roland garros maintenant nous rejoignons
jean mamère jean oui je vous entends
bien alors on va regarder celui qui
reste et s'il n'en reste qu'un c'est
celui-là thierry tulasne
dans le duel franco français l'opposant
à jean-philippe plus rien c'est
finalement en cinq sets que thierry
tulasne s'est imposé un match à
rebondissements entre deux joueurs qui
ne se sont jamais vraiment libéré
en définitive et ilan sera opposée à
l'américaine jill burger le tombeur de
jimmy connors pas de miracle pour jérôme
potier le deuxième français encore en
lice il n'a pu franchir l'obstacle de
l'américaine duncan sans doute pris à
froid
jérôme putin n'a jamais vraiment n'est
jamais vraiment rentré dans le match lui
l'habitué des rencontres marathon est
sorti cette fois en trois sets 6 4 6 0 6
c'est dur même si d'une canne ne s'est
pas toujours montrée des plus fair play
notamment sur la balle de match
car une cantrell elle aura vécu une
belle histoire à roland garros même si
elle est éliminée par la suite africaine
que dr tout est pourtant grand trek a
bien joué le premier set le deuxième fut
beaucoup plus pénible pour la petite
française et elle s'en va avec la
satisfaction d'une même d'avoir été avec
sophie amiach la meilleure joueuse
française de ce tour banderole en garde
c'est dommage que ça soit fini a
aussitôt cet après midi jean que ce
style amplement il ya six sur le central
je ne vais pas vous envoyer l'image la
seule chose que je puisse vous dire
c'est que monica seles vient d'éliminer
in à garrison monica seles que l'on dit
la futur grand du tennis de demain alors
en revanche nous allons nous rendre sur
le court numéro 1 ou en ce moment agassi
est opposé à courrier team courrier
alors agassi dette en bas de votre écran
jim courier andre agassi a perdu le
premier set
le mène maintenant 5 jeux à 3 être 15
égalité dans le deuxième set
donc c'est très bon pour agassi qui se
refait un petit peu il a eu du mal à
entrer dans cette partie est vrai que
jim courier numéro 47 mondial la croche
depuis le début de la rencontre
agassi a du mal à trouver le bon rythme
et c'est une très belle partie entre ces
deux joueurs américains qui se ressemble
d'ailleurs étrangement même s'il n'est
pas à vraiment blanc c'est agassi
l'autre l'est naturellement mais les
deux joueurs jouent avec le revers à
demain aussi et bien d'ailleurs parfois
le coup droit demain et c'est assez
intéressant
il rencontre d'autres fort et rapidement
je voudrais vous rappeler par des grands
résultats de la journée il y à bruyères
un junior qui s'est qualifiée wilander
d'une canne la zec masini y va dîner vic
ed baird tulasne chesnau corps qui sera
le prochain adversaire
il agassi ou de courriers d'ailleurs est
en ce moment même lendl mène deux sets à
zéro et l'américain de chambre s'est
qualifié va se qualifier parce qu'il
mène deux sets à zéro
et quant à agenor il s'est qualifié à
l'instant trois sets à zéro point et
sigean pour ce tour complet de roland
garros son corps un résultat de cyclisme
laurent fignon
c'est une bonne nouvelle a endossé le
maillot rose de leader du tour d'italie
au terme de la 14e étape une des plus
dures de giro avec cinq cols au
programme demain à chantilly le prix du
jockey club le spectacle saura autant
sur la piste que dans les tribunes où
s'affronteront les élégantes pirette
bresse didier rancoeur le prix du
jockey-club lancia c'est la tradition de
l'élégance et le top niveau des courses
la lutte des grands champions premier
favori cash à celui scène s'est promis
de gagner le jeu qui club avec dancehall
qui pensent que c'est un cheval que avec
chaque corse il a fait des progrès il a
fait tout le nécessaire pour être à
l'arrivée les diamants condition que je
pense qu'il est bien et vient bien et
vous mais attention le principal
adversaire de kacha scène et de
dancehall sera galetto que l'on voit ici
gagner le prix lupin de plusieurs
longueurs galetto est lui aussi l'un des
favoris du prix du jockey club rando
club de jean-louis consensus c'est quand
même une conséquence supérieur au prix
du pain
mais enfin disons qu'on arrive dans les
bonnes conditions pour cette course
je suis très optimiste sinon je pense
que vu les performances antérieures je
ne présenterai pas le choix dans cette
course est-ce qu'on peut aller le voir
c'est cheval
moi je préfère pas parce que les chevaux
quand ils sont arrivés à ce stade deux
de préparation ils sont très fragiles
psychologiquement et je préfère qu'il
garde toute son influx nerveux pour des
mouches galetto devra également se
méfier de sovereign water engagés dans
la course au tout dernier moment et qui
peut créer la surprise de ce choc et que
l'aide mais je peux aller très bien
il reste sur une très bonne performance
je suis assez confiant il a une toute
première chance de gagner des lots est
très relevé il ya très bons choix dans
la course mais si le terrain reste ferme
et que la course est très sélective et
pour apprécier sa pointe de vitesse à ce
moment là je pense qu'il a une très
bonne chance
oui mais méfiance car demain après midi
il pleuvra certainement sur l'hippodrome
de chantilly
malheureusement il n'y a que quatorze
chevaux engagés dans ce prix du jockey
club et c'est pas suffisant pour une
course attire c'est alors où nous
propose en échange le et lancia thema
une course en dictant ce qui se déroule
sur 2000 mètres qui elle a réuni seize
chevaux des chevaux venant spécialiste
de ceux ci des preuves à thiers c'est
bien difficile à départager mais
toutefois voici le pronostic que je vous
propose avec en tête steamship le 5 et
pim et us le 9 mai drian le 2
weening empires le 10 mars foule un boys
of no return cette triple wild 4 et reps
le 15 pour terminer 5 9 de 10 1 7 4 et
15 voilà alors à continuer dans les
chiffres je vous donnais les résultats
du tiercé du quartier plus de cet après
midi pour gagner il fallait jouer elle à
11 15 et le 7 562 france 50 ça c'est le
gain et pour ce qui concerne le quarté
vous ajoutez la ce et vous gagnez 2337
francs et 60 centimes voilà avant de
nous quitter je voudrais vous rappeler
que la principale information qui est
tombé dans le courant de ce journal et
qui a été confirmée par notre envoyé
spécial à pékin bruno le dreff les
soldats chinois ont envahi ce soir la
place tiananmen où depuis cette semaine
des pékinois et les étudiants venus de
toute la chine manifester il y a eu des
affrontements le dernier bilan en date
tels que nous les cris l'agencé france
presse fait état de 16 morts et 180
blessés et bruno le dreff
nous lisait également tout à l'heure
lorsqu'il est intervenu les
affrontements se poursuivent et il
entend dans les rues des tirs d'armes
automatiques qui l'a lu également des
milliers d'hommes de troupe se déverser
et s'agglutiner ou dans les alentours de
la place tienanmen bien sûr d'autres
informations dans notre dernier journal
voilà tout de suite après la météo avec
les prévisions de josé blanc lapierre
suivi de champs elysées spéciale elsa et
puis aux alentours de 23h30 donc
philippe gassot avec les toutes
dernières informations spécialement
venus de chine d'ailleurs
et puis ensuite un spécial lunettes
noires consacré aux oscars du rock qui
viennent d'être décernés aux états unis
voilà bonsoir à tous et ce soir tout
spécialement aux téléspectateurs
tunisiens qui depuis 14 heures ce samedi
nous reçoivent par satellite en direct à
titre expérimental espérons que cette
expérience sera concluante en tout cas
bienvenue un bon soir à demain 13h